let's bring in byron york chief
political correspondent for the
washington examiner and foxy
uh contributor byron great to see you
it's been a while good to have you on
the program
you know you look at the mixed messaging
that has come from this white house when
you go back and we've been rolling the
tape ad nauseum
of president biden saying if you are
vaccinated you no longer
need to wear a mask now reportedly they
are
weighing a decision whether or not they
are going to recommend masking
up as this delta variant we're told now
makes up 83
percent of all confirmed cases so
should the buy administration be worried
about that mixed messaging
or will we see them plunge right into
more mass mandates
well i think they should worry about the
anger and confusion
that a change in their mask
recommendation will likely
cause first of all things work
differently in different parts of the
country the the viruses
at different levels in different parts
of the country and practices
are very different all across the
country look at what's happening
in la county in california there's
there's just a war going on out there i
mean there
are dozens and dozens of little cities
in l.a county 10 million people in the
whole county
and they're all mad about having to
adopt
some overall county-wide mass policy
just
think of what you would see if the biden
administration
after that presidential announcement in
may that you just mentioned
comes out with a new mask policy let me
just get your reaction to this because
jen saki is holding her daily briefing
at the white house right now she was
just asked
about this possible decision to tell
americans to
mask up and saki said there is no
decision to change
mask guidance any guidance would come
from the cdc
i mean politically speaking this is a
tough one
because that delta variant is very
contagious we're told not more dangerous
but more contagious byron and we've got
just over 50 percent of this population
uh vaccinated at this point they have
not reached their goals the
administration
well no they haven't uh although the the
number of course of adults is
higher but there's genuine confusion
about this that the
administration needs to address because
uh the the idea has been that the
the vaccine would help fully vaccinated
individuals would prevent them from
getting the disease now there's
a lot of talk now about breakthrough
cases well maybe they're not as serious
and if you have the the vaccination well
you won't have to go to the hospital or
you certainly won't be
on a ventilator or you won't die of it
but and but a number of people are
saying well wait a minute
i thought i was not going to get it at
all so if the government
is changing its position on the vaccine
it needs to be clearer and and also if
it really doesn't know
right now it also needs to be clear
about that
that confusion really came to light
right when those six democrats who fled
texas
who were on the airplane mask list ended
up testing positive when they were in
washington dc and
statistically you couldn't help but
wonder if they were all vaccinated how
how that many people would become
infected i want to move on and i want to
ask you about nancy pelosi responding to
kevin mccarthy calling him ridiculous
for him to recommend
jim banks and jim jordan for the january
6 committee
she says there is no way here's her
explanation byron
we these people are going to act up
cause a problem
and people said to me put them on and
then when they act up you can
take them off i said why should we waste
time on something as predictable when
statements are
ridiculous and fall into the realm of uh
you must be kidding there's no way that
with this decision many republic
republicans calling this all politics a
power grab in washington by nancy pelosi
but with this decision are democrats
just showing they are
throwing out promises of unity for
partisanship
well we we haven't had any unity around
for quite a while
but it's clear that that nancy pelosi
has stepped over a line even though in
the house of representatives
the speaker has just enormous power the
majority has
enormous power more so than in the
senate
still it was unprecedented to to create
a committee uh
with the minority having the authority
to appoint its own members
and then to veto two of those now
republicans felt
that they needed a couple of fighters on
the committee uh because it was going to
be obviously dominated by democrats
because
they're the majority they appointed the
majority of members
so representative jordan for example
was really effective in the first
trump impeachment was a very very uh
articulate spokesman
against the case that democrats had made
for impeaching president trump over the
ukraine matter
so they just nancy pelosi clearly just
doesn't want to bother with that
again it's probably not a good idea for
her to do this
okay we'll see where all of that goes
next great to see you byron thank you so
much
thank you sandra